is my buyers a friend in terms of life
do you I feel like Mike Myers is off
doing his own thing that you guys mm-hm
don't really have a close relationship
which is weird to me um you know it's
funny when we see each other we just
talk all over each other you know he had
two older brothers right he's kind of
small like I was he was bullied a little
bit and then we also have you know the
the connection to loving things British
right you know it's are you upset with
him speaking of loving things British
when he was doing the whole movie about
Austin Powers Austin Powers yes the dr.
evil dr. evil
is an impression of Lorne Michaels boy
and I I heard maybe you don't want to
get into this but but but that Mike's
impression of Lorne was based on your
impression of Lauren and he took it and
and used it as dr. evil and it bugged
you a little bit right because you were
the one who figured out how to do Lauren
when I started there no one did Lauren
the first thing I broke was him in the
meeting in the room this is on a
Wednesday night you've read all the
sketches and he's trying to move these
cards around to figure out what the
show's gonna be and he has it in act
like a Broadway show that's Lauren's big
thing yeah the first act and he doesn't
have any cards there and he would say he
would say before you use the bathroom
behind him you go oh I still have no
[ __ ] first act and that was what
broke it for me I still have no [ __ ]
first letter what other words when I say
broke it for you you heard him say that
and you heard the music of his voice
yeah and then after that it was just
going this thing of like you never
underestimate the value of water and
he's a fascinating guy I mean I
brilliant guy the thing that's happened
to me the last time I did a guest spot
on SNL maybe a year ago or something I
just decided I'm gonna stay all night
with Lauren because I'd always baby out
at like 3:30 or 4:00 and Lauren doesn't
get tired so how does he do that I don't
understand he just talked non-stop and
he comes up with stuff and you go where
does he come up with this stuff but for
me it's it's like with Mike too you know
it's getting late I I don't I have a lot
of affection for him I mean the
they ripped over the dr. evil Karen we
never really talked about it I talked
about it to the therapist and I
basically let it go
you did but yeah I felt that for a while
you felt like gee you know the dr. evil
character is Lauren obviously and in
order it's a funny thing with
impressions once somebody figures it out
yes and it all works and do it the best
way to learn and and you know part of
you know Mike's talent is his ability to
see things like so for him to pick out
Bohemian Rhapsody for Wayne's world was
a brilliant thing and when I finally did
the impression for Lorne you know it's
the thing and the pinkie thing was a
made up thing Lauren doesn't do that but
somehow it fit you know you came up with
the pinkie things well the pinkie thing
I did do yeah yeah yeah so I understand
this from a musician's standpoint and
since you see things musically if a guy
writes a song that's his baby yeah when
you come up with an impression it's kind
of your baby right and so when you go to
the premiere of a movie and you're
rooting for Mike because he's your buddy
and you known him all these years
mm-hm and then you see dr. evil it's
like waiting that's the song I wrote
that's the music I heard in my head and
the key thing is that thing that I
uniquely do but you know what it's it's
I did it backstage I just thought well I
can't do this
publicly cuz you know I'm gonna be
biting Lorne Michaels the hand that fed
me right but in the end of the day I
have to say that Mike the construct of
Austin Powers was brilliant and it's a
it's a great character and he you know
after a while everyone started doing
Lauren you know right but I think in the
end of the day as you go through life
and you get beat up by all kinds of
things or I go I was very lucky to
intersect with Mike Myers sure you know
what I mean so you get a bigger
perspective when when life gets tough
right so you know did you pick up the
phone and call and say hey you know I
know I've been harboring a resentment
and I am now kind of over it I just want
you to know that I haven't done that I
haven't done that I'd like to do it on
you know national rate we can do that
now address Mike Myers